title of this video is maximizing the
deal
[Music]
that's our boy Mr Beast hey I love Mr
Beast week here at JK this week let's
talk about how this guy just turned down
a billion dollar offer for his channel
so why I want to know why I want to know
how I want to know
what he's liquid do you think he's it's
because he's dumb as [ __ ] I mean dude I
I think there's a lot of image behind
him for some reason I think he's a
really smart kid he's smart but I think
that there's something behind him where
he thinks that having money sucks and
like makes him look like [ __ ] and I'm
like
please stop doing that because it makes
me feel like [ __ ] because I want that
you know what I think it is I think my
ideas suck ass so they're under a
billion dollars so for me I'm like a
billion dollar buyout that's awesome
give it to me but his ideas are probably
above a billion dollars so he's like
this is too small I could scale my [ __ ]
way bigger Martin how the [ __ ] can you
think that how can you think anything's
above a billion dollars just one billion
just [ __ ] a billion dollars think
about what you could do with the billion
dollars you could move your mom out of
that shitty house
that's what I'm thinking that's it but
he's thinking other things oh my God so
would he still be able to do like a
different Channel or compete well let's
go let's go and give to uh again there's
not a lot of information a lot of it's
hypothetical because it's probably a
sign of NDA you can't talk but but we'll
go we'll go into the context of it maybe
he enjoys it so much that he'd rather do
what he does now than lose a sense of
identity or purpose I think that's what
it is for sure because it's like a
billion dollars or be like what the [ __ ]
am I gonna do or he's just betting on
himself ironically though okay so even
in this sense if somebody were to quote
unquote buy his whatever the [ __ ] his
YouTube channel is Comfort his company
is Mr beagle the Beast likeness whatever
the [ __ ] use of his penis whatever it is
yeah whatever it is
he would in fact there would be some
sort of negotiated term whether it be
one year three year five years whatever
that he still has to run that company
that he makes sense that was pretty of
course that happens a lot yeah so like
let's say I come in I'm like I got a
billion dollars and I buy Mr Beast for a
billion dollars even though I buy I
can't just be like all right cool now I
have Mr Beast and like what do I do with
the channel I start making my own
content as Anthony no it doesn't work
right Mr Beast is obligated for whatever
our negotiated term is let's say I would
negotiate like you know three years with
him you still gotta run Mr Beast entity
as whatever the [ __ ] you but you're not
Your Own Boss anymore yeah but you're
not your own boss exactly and I might
still be like hey you're doing such a
great job of it which is why I want to
purchase it that you can do anything you
want you just have to [ __ ] go with
100 at this thing for the next three
years right that that would be my basic
analysis if I had money to throw away at
a YouTube content creator that was
basically his own entity you like you're
not buying like a conglomerate you're
not buying like Adidas or this or that
you're buying like a person's identity
so it's it's totally built on the
shoulders of that person's creative
there's no way that that deal would be
formed without needing to rely on that
person being a part of the establishment
of that purchase for minimum three years
but that's exactly the problem that this
guy has with it and is what he does not
make smart decisions again I'm gonna
thought the fact that he's 23 years old
oh for [ __ ] that is crazy I knew that
that would make certain people feel a
certain way I can tell you what if
someone goes I'll buy JK for a billion
dollars I'm like [ __ ] bring out the
paperwork right [ __ ] now oh I'm gonna
kick your ass
bar would say bring on a wood chipper
too we're chucking Talon in
so I do want to ask again his thing he
said he said
quote like you know a billion dollars if
we could own the channel and the
companies and stuff like that and I'm
like oh that sounds exciting or enticing
but I don't know if I would want to work
for my YouTube channel
because he's 23 maybe I don't know
should we just have like a lack of
lack in your own image like the
dichotomy of that
insulted all the people who
will get into a more detailed shipping
structure for the sake of this
conversation and I'm also I'm also
insulting him from a place of I know
he's seven thousand times smarter than I
am yeah totally [ __ ] it that's not what
you said bar originally so I'm gonna
stick to that however with I will start
if somebody gave me a billion dollars to
buy hinges right now sure buy here just
100 absolutely [ __ ] five years
obviously and I'll suck your dick every
[ __ ] day would you wear a hat that
says [ __ ] hinges though for that much I
just did it for free
a billion dollars me personally kinjaz
is online my song I know if you're
listening to this you need to subscribe
if you're listening to this here's a
[ __ ] just hat God damn it I hate that
I did that I like that that's a great
picture that's probably the best picture
I've seen in you point is amazing I will
[ __ ] sign it no questions asked even
if there's something in there where I
gotta like you know once a year get like
a finger in my butt for [ __ ] three
years
I will [ __ ] do it by the way that's
where the mail process it is so it's
probably a good deal which is why I'll
pay them a fee for it now where are you
guys 100 million no no no turn I said
billion okay billion dude no [ __ ]
questions asked bam sign okay dude
you're just repeating what I said it's
very boring
you send Joe into a North Korea
's what's the least amount you it's you
sell JK Joe goes to a North Korean labor
camp what do you say yeah and what
happens and what's the amount and nobody
will ever see Joe again yeah wait what
Joe goes to a North Korean labor camp
you sold JK clandestine under flight of
night but you got to sell JK good for
you by the way capitalist [ __ ] yeah you
capitalist piece of [ __ ] you get to sell
your business party you piece of [ __ ]
but hey good for you he's going to a
North Korean labor camp and you'll never
hear from them again what's the least
amount of money you have to take that
includes you don't have to hear from him
about Japan again either so it might be
a benefit to you and by the way suddenly
suddenly it's Bart Malia I don't think I
like that that's funny
now you're talking you might even love
it there you won't know yeah I think
you'll love the exercise in the outdoors
that they get because the fact that
Joe's not in it art Malia
think about it I might even sell it just
to have that happen and then I'll buy
the channel back so I'm like Joe's not
even here oh [ __ ]
do you think Joe would do the same thing
to you probably yeah probably definitely
definitely we've been trying to buy each
other out for years go with cell JK for
a huge amount of money and then he would
buy a plane
he'd buy a bunch of planes what's the
[ __ ] plane we've been trying to
[ __ ] poison each other's drinks for
years okay no serious serious serious
serious concept serious hypothetical
what's the least amount of money you
have to accept to sell yourself your
your business I just asked you the
question 100 million I'm the host I'm
those I'm saying the least amount of
money you make up the number yourself
for JK JK and barbell all of you wow all
of it all of it in one Ah that's weird
I'll do one at a time okay fine that's
weird you didn't like that one no
because my brain doesn't work like that
it's not smart like Anthony's one at a
time [ __ ] oh hey good good impression
you went straight to [ __ ] autistic
came Anthony holy [ __ ] that was good um
JK
probably 10 million
that's it
why the [ __ ] are we here
[ __ ] are we doing
what the [ __ ] are you getting paid dude
10 million oh [ __ ] you 10 million is
enough for our four percent what's that
guy me me and Joe to have I don't know
maybe like two to like three million
each we take the rest we split almost
everyone has been rocking with us
it's [ __ ] sick you give some to the
Riders huh
10 million is you and Joe take two to
three million each that's upwards to 6
million the rest is tax
um depending on where you live the rest
of us get ten thousand dollars depending
on where you live not for us you
[ __ ] number all right so you
went from ten thousand dollars to Thirty
Grand great job
dumb [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] it's like 30
Rex I got 30 racks and I boil it at 150
degree weather
30 racks that goes straight to my AC I
got 10 million because of where I live
set of six does that make you happy so I
got eight JK is not a 100 Vegas entity
you know that me it should be
but because a couple hold out pieces of
[ __ ] on this side of the room boom boom
boom Joe will keep six and we'll take
the two and we split it amongst the
people have been riding with that did
you say you'll take 16 you'll take the
two and split it no me and Joe will take
six that's three and three and they'll
take two and we split it amongst they
split four with us yeah and hopefully
they remember the people who were cool
to them and not pieces of [ __ ] like like
the three here
hey what about you people who moved to
Nevada people who were chilling cool
what about barbell
barbell
if you say anything over 10 I'm
literally leaving right now he's gonna
say something over the intent I know he
is that's what I'm saying he's gonna be
wondering really literally the ability
to inspire your co-workers right now
barbell has so much merge
you guys have supplements I think it
would be the same thing probably like
10. wow probably ten
all right same thing I think for me it's
not so much about money or maximizing
the deal that's not what I'm after we're
totally talking about money and
maximizing oh I don't care about Max
maybe maybe I'm like title of this video
is maximizing the deal
maybe I'm I'm with Mr Beast on this I'm
not set up I'm not about maximizing the
deal there there's already a lifestyle
that I'm after so I know that I don't
need anything more than that okay so for
me if I can achieve that lifestyle
forever then that makes me happy so it's
not about maximizing like squeezing
every lap at any point was JK or barbell
did anyone ever offer to buy it
uh I don't think so what's this wow
we're close enough
what's this thing like we we don't own
the revenue on the channel like you you
sold it to somebody oh licensing yeah
yeah licensing so uh there's this thing
called the spotter or whatever where
they buy like
videos or they they're able to use the
content that you have
from I think like
the beginning of the channel up to like
five years or two years whatever
and then they license it so the ads they
have full control of their ads so they
are able to take their margins and like
let's say if this is what the YouTube ad
revenue is they make their money by okay
well I'll pay you what YouTube's gonna
pay you and then but whatever I sell for
extra I take that word much Mr Beast is
also involved in spawning yeah yeah
because that was the billion dollar part
of that really obviously oh yeah yeah
for sure oh yeah
they wanted to take over his channel and
like after the ads oh I see for sure I
think it's pretty cool that it shows
like how much he views his own life
Legacy as being what he wants it to be
because if he sells it's worth more than
mine he has such a big fandom that would
not like that yeah they just wouldn't
like it even if he gets a billion
dollars they're not the kind that's
gonna you know nobody is no one's fandom
he's gonna like that and like imagine if
he had to step outside of himself and
not be who he is right so he has to like
it's a good at Best Buy and like don't
stand outside of the red circle and
stack that now you have to stand and
sign like you know something like
[ __ ] polygon or some [ __ ] he's like
that's not who I am
I'm not gonna make people stack a bunch
of electronics inside of a polygon
that's [ __ ] hack [ __ ] I wanted a red
circle and so like for him he's like I
want to make that call you know I want
to [ __ ] stand up say I'm Mr Beast and
like I want people to [ __ ] stack that
[ __ ] inside of a pentagon not a circle
oh also it's kind of a it's a kind of a
cool Power move that I like drunk Steve
if it's a public story that you're being
offered a billion and you publicly
declined it doesn't the value of your
channel go up from just that action
alone yeah for sure the speculative
value absolutely but I'll tell you what
a billion dollars is a billion dollars
you don't know if you're gonna get a
second billion dollar offer in your life
I think I think that's something to
weigh out no matter from Snapchat
Snapchat those are like unique
one-of-one stories yeah but Mr Beast is
a 101. I want to put out an
advertisement anybody wants to buy JK
for 10 million dollars yeah put in the
comments at one time Smosh was the Mr
Beast at another time Hugo was the Smosh
like everybody should have taken this
billion dollar deal now that's what I
understand you know I've never seen it
work the other way
every wave crashes when you get the best
offer of your life I think at your Peak
too yeah it's reasonable to take it the
biggest [ __ ] you Surfer Dudes I'm too
hippy to care sold to Disney when I was
there I was there they sold the Disney
for a billion and that's smart and [ __ ]
you out but you know what those cats
look like sellout blah blah blah blah
blah to their friend group who gives up
no one remembers
billion dollars is so much money like
people can Thrive off of like two
hundred thousand a hundred thousand
dollars a year like have a stress-free
lifestyle
my pillows
she's like because I have a stress for
your life I'm like Nick you know what
Nick you would say people could Thrive
off like
15 30 million dollars I'm like yeah I
know where the pillow budget is
[Music]
[Music]